sales at its highest level is the
transference of emotion so whenever we
buy anything we buy on emotion and we
justify with the logical mind this is
why you know the 55 year old guy goes
out and buys the candy apple red
Corvette and then comes home and tells
his wife about the great gas mileage the
Primary Emotion that must be transferred
is certainty think about the last time
you spent a thousand dollars or more and
I guarantee you you had three tens you
had a 10 uncertainty that the product of
the service would solve your problem or
get your needs met you had a 10 in that
the company would stand behind the the
deal if something went wrong and you
would attended the person you were
buying from that if I was buying this
car or this new roof or this air
conditioning from Sam or from Mary that
if something went wrong Sam or Mary had
the gravitas and the stick and the
ability to get my problem solved
confused people do nothing and so where
is our client supposed to get certainty
if not from you they have to get
certainty so you have to come across
sharp as attack you have to come across
as 100 believable Dependable reliable I
want to build so much certainty in
anybody that I'm working with that I'm a
pro that I can get it done that I am
that go-to person that if they need
something they can with 100 certainty
know that I'm going to deliver for them
and I think that's critically important
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip I'm excited to be back with you I
have a special guest Paul Martinelli
here in the house Paul is a legend he's
an entrepreneur he's a speaker he's an
author he's a builder he's a coach we're
gonna spend a lot of time talking about
coaching today he's worked with some of
your favorite thought leaders of all
time he's partnered with guys like Zig
Ziglar and Jack Canfield and John
Maxwell and some of the biggest names in
the industry he's trained
tens of thousands yeah tens of thousands
I I always say either directly trained
or created the system in which uh more
people have been certified speakers and
coaches and trainers and anybody in the
world living or dead yeah over uh what a
billion revenue of yeah billion dollars
in revenue and from coaching yeah from
coach in in the information like
coaching speaking training yeah business
so so we get to pick his brain here
today I'm I'm on site in Arizona and
Paul was here like we got to get Paul we
gotta get Paul to start come in and give
you guys some love and so we're gonna
start by me asking Paul some questions
about coaching I know a lot of you
either already have a coaching program
set up but you're thinking about getting
into coaching and then we're gonna do
some coaching because Paul's a great
coach if you think about this group
right here some of them are full-time
coaches some of them are part-time
coaches some of them are speakers
authors and want to get into the
coaching business they're not
necessarily looking to get somebody
else's training like I want to be a
licensed under whoever right what advice
do you have for them at this stage to
build and grow their coaching practice
Yeah so there's a couple things I think
the most important thing is is you you
have to make a determination whether you
were going to be a true purist in
coaching right so people like ICF hate
me right because they're purists I I
kind of lean towards kind of a mentoring
blend with coaching so maybe even
content coaching where I would coach you
through content right so there's a
curriculum to the coaching which drives
in traditional coaches nuts but I think
what you'll find in the marketplace is
that when somebody hires you as a coach
at some point in that Dynamic and and in
every coaching relationship there's a
dynamic that takes place
that
that client wants you to to be directive
they they want you to tell them what to
do right and so you have to make a
decision if you're willing to to be that
type of coach and I would recommend that
you do it it certainly pays better
um because most people get really
frustrated
um especially when they're when they're
paying out of their own pocket companies
not paying for it they're looking for
answers they're looking for a return on
investment and they're looking for
solution I think the second thing is is
you have to you have to know your value
and you have to be able to communicate
and articulate your value
uh I have watched lots of really good
kids really great coaches raise skinny
kids because you know they're the best
kept secret and they they do know how to
communicate their value and I think
that's if there's a skill set that you
need to learn as a coach is you need to
learn how to sell you need to be able to
establish your value
discover what the problem is that you're
solving for your client
you need to as soon as you know that
okay this is a problem that I can solve
for Evan the next thing I want to do in
that sales conversation is I want to
make I want to make Evan acutely aware
of his problem
because I'll I'll give you an example
you may be working with somebody and
they say you know our problem here is is
um you know we've got a a communication
problem with our team well
that's really a symptom because what's
breaking down the communication is
probably Trust
and and I can tell you this people will
pay a lot more and a lot quicker to
solve a trust issue within the
organization than they will to break
down a communication issue and so being
able to take somebody through that what
I call intelligence gathering when you
first meet someone and you're you're
trying to uncover what their problem is
where most coaches make the mistake is
as soon as the client says you know this
is my problem we come in as saviors
because that's what we write we are
agents of change we want to we want to
help other people right we want to we
want to remove pain so we oh don't worry
you know I can help you well you've let
that person off the hook you wanna you
wanna antagonize that problem so tell me
more about that tell me what that looks
like tell me how that's costing you tell
me tell me you know what's what's the
current game plan to solve this problem
and chances are they don't have one well
if you don't have one what does this
look like you know what does this
problem look like if it were to manifest
itself in its most natural expression
what's it look like in the next six
months and and that's a grim picture so
I'm future pacing them to the negative
and making them acutely aware that they
have to make this decision and so you've
got to be able to sell yourself guys
you've got to know your value
and you've got to be able to articulate
your value and I think the last thing is
is you got to be willing to blow your
own horn you've got to be a
self-promoter I had an opportunity to
meet a guy by the name of Ken Craig and
I he's passed he's one of those we were
talking earlier like just Legends you
wish you would have been and I met him
he was um he's famous for he represented
uh Cyndi Lauper and Lionel Richie and
Willie Nelson but he did Hands Across
America and he did we are the world he
organized those things and what he was
famous for was was promoting himself and
stars and he said what happens is most
people we've been programmed at a very
early age that you know promoting
ourselves as arrogance and it's not
arrogance it's it's awareness I mean you
were clearly you know the Godfather in
your space right you you are you're a
leader there and for you to marginalize
or diminish yourself in in that respect
um
diminishes then your value or your
perceived value in the marketplace so
you have to be able to find an elegant
way to feather in
the contribution and the achievements
that you have and make sure that the
person you're talking to knows your
value you can't assume they do
I used to struggle a lot with that and
maybe still do because at some point I
mean I think it's the nice Canadian side
that that comes in of
I would have knowledge that I knew could
help people but didn't push on it enough
and then you see them making the
mistakes and then I would end up taking
that person I was like well if I was
just more bold
in my commentary if I didn't let them
off the hook because I think there's
always this fear and I'd love for you to
speak to it sure that you never have a
hundred percent certainty
you might have like 80 or 85 percent or
90 certain that your that your thing is
the right thing for them and we hang on
to that couple percentage of doubt that
this may not be the answer for them and
then the client or Prospect feels that
doubt as well then they say well this
isn't the person for me 100 so how do
you get over that doubt yeah so there's
a couple things first off um
I'll I'll come back and Define what
sales is my definition of sales but you
know the problem you're speaking to goes
right to you know a self-identity so in
our subconscious mind
our our self-image is established there
and our self-esteem and the two are very
different right so self-image is the
image that I hold of myself and the
image that I believe you see me
self-esteem is my personal self-regard
how I value me and so one of the
exercises and I grew up in a single
family home with a
the the childhood home that I grew up in
was not a safe place it wasn't a safe
place physically it wasn't a safe place
emotionally
and um at a young age I developed a
stutter and if you know anything about
stuttering most people who stutter it's
not a neurological issue it's an
emotional issue it's usually a
self-image or self-esteem issue and so I
was so afraid to speak because if I
spoke i i i i risked you know being hit
and so my self-confidence and my
self-belief was so low I ended up
failing out of school and one of the
biggest challenges I had as a as a young
entrepreneur was this being able to
believe in myself this is the work of in
the 1960s the phenomenal work of Dr
Maxwell maltz where he said you know in
his book psycho cybernetics psyche is
the Greek word for mind cybernetics is
the science and control of electronical
systems and so our our subconscious mind
works is this mechanism the servo
mechanism that you never outperform your
own self-image and so
one of the exercises that I did to break
through this was like you couldn't pay
me a compliment if you said you know wow
you know you did a great job I'd say
well the team really did it or if you
said well you look nice they'd say well
yeah my wife dressed like you couldn't
pay me a compliment as soon as somebody
would say anything nice to me I would
immediately deflect marginalize myself
at diminish myself and I didn't even
know I was doing it I mean I was I was a
professional self-saboteur
and so one of the one of the the tricks
to overcome this and man was this hard
was it when somebody would pay me a
compliment the only thing I could say to
them was thank you for noticing
like I had to just accept it like thank
you for like somebody said wow that was
a great talk
thank you for noticing
and I you know I would want to run and
take a shower because it just it just
didn't it just didn't feel right you
know I just it's just like oh my
goodness so it goes back to we have to
know our value because if we don't
sales
at its highest level
is the transference of emotion
good so whenever we buy anything we buy
on emotion and we justify with the
logical mind this is why you know the 55
year old uh the guy goes out and buys
the candy apple red Corvette and then
comes home and tells his wife about the
great gas mileage right so so he's
buying On Emotion he's justifying with
logic so sales at its highest level is
the transference of emotion the Primary
Emotion that must be transferred
is certainty and that's the word you use
and so think about the last time you
spent a thousand dollars or more
and I guarantee you you had three tens
you had a 10 in certainty that the
product of the service would solve your
problem or get your needs met
you had a 10 in that the company would
stand behind the the deal if something
went wrong and you would attend the
person you were buying from that if I
was buying this car or this new roof or
this air conditioning from Sam or from
Mary that if something went wrong Sam or
Mary had the gravitas and the stick and
the and the ability to get my problem
solved
if you don't have three tens and
certainty
um
infused people do nothing
right confused people do nothing and so
where where
is our client supposed to get certainty
if not from you they have to get
certainty so you have to be you have to
come across sharp as attack right you
have to you have to come across as 100
believable Dependable reliable you know
this this morning
um you know we were supposed to meet at
at 7 15. I was here at 6 45. and I was
already here I didn't know we're already
here you were already here because this
is
and what you see is yeah you see an
expression of two pros and we just we're
we're not even going to come close to
risking you know our reputation or and
and we see it as that no you know we
don't think of it like oh my goodness if
I'm not you know if I'm not 15 minutes
early Evan's not going to see me as a
professional it's now in great it's it's
now part of who I am I just that's just
the way it is is that I want I want to I
want to build so much certainty in
anybody that I'm working with that that
I'm a pro that I can get it done that
I'm an expert at what I do that I'm
dependable and reliable that I am that
go-to person that if they need something
they can with 100 certainty know that
I'm going to deliver for them and I
think that's critically important so you
can't transfer that level of certainty
marginalizing yourself you simply can't
yeah I used to think that I sucked as a
salesperson and I think for most of the
sales training and all the types of
closes I would bomb on all of those use
the negative reverse selling technique
and framework and all of all of this
stuff but I'm actually
a great salesperson I discovered just by
believing in the other person it's like
I believe so much in what you can create
and so if you're a coach like you
believe so much in the change that the
person can create that
they don't even have to believe it they
just have to believe that you believe
that's right they borrow the belief yeah
it's true so as long as they believe
that you but so it's like your energy
your excitement your enthusiasm for the
change that they can make is the thing
that they get hooked on to and and I
think that's so critically important in
that in the in the first 15 seconds
they've got to know that you 100 believe
in them and how do you do that I think
there's several things one is you know
certainly body language
as soon as somebody is if somebody's
sharing you know their mental model of
perfection for their future their dream
if you will if you look away or look
down subconsciously it registers that
they that you don't believe in second is
your tonality your facial expressions
like when somebody starts to tell me
about their dream
I I can't help myself I look directly in
their eyes and my face says tell me more
like I wanna wow that is amazing you
know and what I'm saying in my mind when
somebody's sharing their their future
with me is I'm saying I see that and I
believe that in you nice and that that's
your job as a coach your job is to be
the first person to believe in this
person because let's face it a dreamer
is surrounded by Skeptics right a
dreamer surrounded by you know the men
in white coats waiting to take them away
because they're The Crazy Ones right
we're nuts you know again I'm a high
school dropout I'll tell her can I share
a disability
I'm 22 years old uh and I am I am going
in the wrong direction in my life and I
am picking up speed right I'm you know
life is not life is not good I'm a high
school dropout
and um I'm at
I'm at my mom's house for Thanksgiving
so it's an Italian you know Thanksgiving
and all of my you know brothers and
sisters are there my grandmother's there
and I announced the family that I'm
going to start a commercial I'm going to
start a cleaning company right I've got
200 bucks in the bank I'm gonna buy a
used vacuum cleaner bottle Windex a
bottle pledge and I'm going the business
and like all all at the same time
everybody's sport you know click click
click click here all the all the forks
hit the play right
and you know
my one brother who has a PHD in in
engineering from Carnegie Mellon
University you know you know goes in on
you know you don't know anything about
business math you know my other brother
who is uh who who uh graduated from a
University of Pittsburgh with the degree
in microbiology he said you know what do
you know about business my mom's telling
me you know remember your bedroom when
you were a key teenager but my
grandmother who was you know but
remember these are my partners in belief
at this moment right my grandmother who
is the love of my life that my soul
right the my biggest champion she says
let's call Roe maybe she can get him in
so row is my cousin Rose who works at
the post office right and so my
grandmother's highest hope for me was
let's call cousin Rose and maybe Paul
can be a male deliverer and he'll forget
this entrepreneurial trade right these
were my partners in belief right yeah
and and so when your client is coming to
you
with a hope with the drain
you you may be you may be that only
person
only person who believes in them and I
think about it if if you look at any
achievement that you know significant
achievement that you've had in your life
you did so on the borrowed belief of
other people and so never underestimate
your power as a coach to influence and
and to serve people
even if they don't hire you
your job is is is to believe in them and
to see them in their highest good that's
your job
I love it I mean I love talking about
belief that's great
um
yeah I think if you can just tap into
your heart
it's so much more valuable than like
memorizing a script or making sure that
you ask this question because more
important than the words that you say is
the emotion behind it that transfer of
certainty 100 I love that it's the
tonality that comes out in toenail if
you think about what tonality is is
tonalogy is is the vibrational frequency
of your thought that's what tonality is
and people people pick that up they feel
that
what would you recommend for marketing
and growing the business we were talking
beforehand about there's a lot of great
speakers who then like don't know how to
build a business yeah they're almost
unemployable afterwards after they get
off stage 100 you know members here they
want to build their coaching practice up
what are some of the steps they can take
to build it yeah so I've been blessed I
mean there's no other way to say it I've
been blessed now I've I've participated
in that blessing you know what I mean I
was partners with Les Brown for about
three years and arguably on any day of
the week Les Brown's the best speaker in
the world he's just he's my favorite
speaker young Les Brown is my favorite
yeah of all time it doesn't get any
better than that yeah yeah
um and you know if you ever get with
them ask them to tell you the Gladys
he's married to Gladys Knight right and
you gotta you gotta have him tell those
stories but that's back when Les Brown
was like he's a you know he's in the
Georgia Dome with 80 yeah yeah yeah you
gotta be hungry yeah and Legend right
and um we uh we are doing uh six or
seven cities together for Subway
Corporation so when the subway
corporators were doing their Subway
challenge
and so we're all from City to City to
City and we get to a sitting we've got
kind of a day off
and so we're in the hotel
and uh you know I'm upstairs uh you know
I'm doing emails I'm watching TV
at around one o'clock I figure I'd go
downstairs I'm gonna grab lunch
I go downstairs and I'm in sweatpants
and in comes through the revolving door
of the hotel we're staying is Les Brown
and he's in uniform you know what I mean
he's got the white shirt the red tie the
black secret that said I mean he came
out that way he'll go out that way
that's out west he's like Bob Proctor
what are you talking about Bob Proctor
always this in the uniform Brian Tracy
always in the uniform right
and um I'm like last like
like what are you doing like you're all
like you're all dressed up we're we're
earlier and he said um
he's out speaking at like uh like a
homeless shelter or something
so here here here's the top speaker in
the world
at a homeless shelter
and I said
at a homeless shelter and he said this
he said speakers
speak
and man I mean I was convicted that
quick that here's the top guy in the
world and he's not going to let it
there's an audience somewhere and so one
of the things I think for coaches is
most coaches I think underestimate the
the power and being able to communicate
as a speaker
and you can't afford the luxury of not
developing that area of talent you have
to
and so not only do speakers speak I
think coaches speak the the greatest way
for you to be able to get hired is for
people to see you communicate it's
probably the most valuable skill you can
develop you know in in terms of
professional development that way in in
your in your art or in your craft and so
you know most coaches would think that
they can't lead a group in silent prayer
right they don't you know I'm not you
know that's why I wanted to coaching
because I don't want to be a speaker but
you have to be able to speak
and I think if all things being equal
you have to ask yourself every single
day like what's what's the what's the
very best use of my time to be effective
and efficient in this very moment and
there's two things one is
delivering on services that you've been
paid or are being paid for
or speaking or doing something in some
form of marketing to get paid clients
everything else you should be hiring out
if you can or should be doing after
hours and so when I started uh you know
I I sold my cleaning company in 2006
partnered with Bob Proctor you know
invested in his company
and uh I went out and almost every
single day I was doing what I called
lunch and learns I would go door to door
to door to door and ask people if I
could come in and do you know a 30 or 40
minute preview TalkBack I would talk on
purpose Vision goals
and although I never charged for that
that talk I never spoke for free you
know what I mean it always turned into
it always turned into another
opportunity for them to come to the
workshop for them to hire me as a coach
so I think as as a coach you want to be
able to know kind of what is your core
philosophy I think having you and I
probably have something very much in
common in terms of one of my one of my
core tenets of my teaching is the
development of self belief right and
self-image it's critically important uh
and so I I will go and I will speak on
that and I think you have to think about
what it is
when you're when you're coaching
somebody what is your true area of
giftedness in helping somebody unlock
their potential and can you create a you
know a 20-minute you know infomercial on
yourself where it comes across genuine
and strategic where you're genuinely
adding value and and I'm talking about
in 20 minutes there should be 17 minutes
of what I call pen grabbing moments
where you're talking and people are just
like they can't get their pen out fast
enough and and so what what lands really
well is you know seven steps ten things
five things because as soon as you you
know are again most people are a program
that as soon as somebody says let me
give you three things the first thing
they're gonna do is they're gonna start
to write down their three things right
they're gonna take notes on those three
things and so you should have whatever
is your core belief your core modality
you should be able to put that in a very
elegant package that positions you as a
problem solver and creates a message in
the mind of The Listener that this is
both a buyer's journey and a learner's
Journey
the transition from moving from free to
paid so you talked about you know you're
doing these lunch and learns or lunch
and learns you're going in it's free but
you end up getting clients you talked
about leaning into the pain and tell me
more about that instead of solving the
problem in the call how do you get
somebody who's on a free session and
move them to becoming a paid client of
yours yeah you have to ask
for the offer right and so you have to
be able
to again this it's this buyer's journey
in every great religion what they have
in common is that there's a future
promise right there's some future
promise of of a beautiful day right and
so you have to whenever you're speaking
whenever you're meeting with somebody
you need to be very clear about where
where am I taking this person so for
instance let's say I would go into a
dare engineering they just popped in my
mind because I sold them probably a 10
000 contract on a free lunch and learn
and I would say hey look you know one of
one of the way you know I'm I'm a
professional speaker uh I help people
you know achieve you know better results
in in any of their lives I can help your
team be more effective while always I
introduce myself to the community is
through you know a free lunch and learn
really simple you get 10 or 50 year
people you buy salads and pizzas I come
in I do a 45 minute talk in the first
five minutes if I'm not nailing it for
you you're just gonna go like this I'll
pack up you'll never have to see me
again but if I do if I do if I do
deliver value
um I'm gonna I'm gonna ask that you just
give me 15 minutes to talk about how we
can have a a more formal relationship so
I would never I would never do something
for free without that caveat being
established that when I'm done we're
gonna talk and in that talk that's when
I would sell and so I would say geez you
know wow you got a really great team you
know most of the people I work with are
trying to get their people to change
your people are leaning into change and
um I think a really good next step I
think you owe it to these people you
know they they want to grow and and to
be honest with you Jim people don't
leave companies because they're not
getting paid they're leaving because
they're they're not growing people
people will leave to grow someplace else
and so I'd like to help you develop a
culture of growth here and so one of the
things that I would do is uh let's do a
a mastermind study so it would be a book
study on thinking we're rich or want a
John Maxwell's book or seven habits of
highly effective people and I would sell
them that for you know you've got you've
got 15 people why don't we do I don't
know two hundred dollars
um per person so it's you know I'm
walking out with a three thousand dollar
deal for for six weeks right and then in
those six weeks on I'm selling the next
step and so I think if I'm talking to a
client one-on-one often coaches will
give a complimentary session right it's
a 30-minute Discovery call or something
like that
if that if you're doing a 30-minute
Discovery call 10 minutes of that call
should be a should be a direct ask a
third of whatever time if you're on
stage if you're speaking for an hour my
belief is 20 minutes of that talk is the
pitch now it needs to be wrapped in
content and so that it doesn't feel that
way so they don't feel like you're being
you know pitched as I'm describing my
program they're actually
taking notes while I'm telling them the
offer and it's the next
emotionally right thing to do for them
and so I think
what you have to do is you have to have
an offer one of the things I like to do
is work with people and help them double
their income right that's one of the
when when Bob Proctor and I worked
together that was our whole stick is
that we're going to help you double your
income or turn your annual income into a
monthly income what happens for most
people is they immediately reject that
idea but you know that's very possible
it's very possible when I was with the
John Maxwell team we had uh in year five
I think or six we did 10 million and the
next year we did 20 million and you know
nobody thought it was possible on my
team right
um but I did I knew you know look if we
can figure out how to do 10 one time all
I'm suggesting we figure out how to do
it one more time right it's not that
hard and so the problem is is that most
most coaches don't have an offered so
I'll say to somebody if I wanted to
spend ten thousand dollars with me today
could I and most well yeah and they they
start making up the program that would
be 10 well now it's too late now yeah
right I'd assume you spent a thousand
dollars with you anything think of a
buyer's Journey like if you were to go
to my website and I'm not I'm this isn't
a pitch but if you were to go to my
website you could sign up for a free
daily thought you can buy an MP3 used to
be a DVD for 9.99 then there's one for
29.99 that is one for 49.99 then there's
a 99 program there's 190 all the way up
to a hundred thousand dollars you can
buy a package and so be easy to do
business with have something to sell
that solves a problem or helps people
meet their need and be able to
communicate the value of you delivering
that with them I think that's the most
important thing yeah I love and we've
talked about packages before guys too
you're thinking about coaching it's not
just coming in one time it's hiding up
that's it's an annual program how do you
come in every week for a year what does
that look like or every month for a year
what does that look like think of that
in advance as you're talking to the
client because it's just so much easier
and your work isn't done just one off no
right you're coming in to need your
ongoing presence coaching guidance I
think what you you have to understand is
is that
the way you get paid right is the way
everybody gets read so there's this law
of compensation right so law
compensation is very clear it tells us
that the amount of money you're going to
make
is dependent on the need for what you do
your ability to do it
and the difficulty there is in replacing
you
and so first off the need is you you had
you you had nothing to do with creating
the need there's only one source of
supply and so I I think I think God or
the universe infinite intelligence
whatever your map of the world says that
need just exists
it's it's already there so there is a
need for what you do the next is your
ability to do it and unfortunately we
Mass produce average we I mean this was
the whole work of Jim Collins good to
great right and you don't have great
schools because you've got average
school you know you've got good is the
enemy of great right and so most most
coaches really never like I said most
coaches will never develop the ability
to to speak you've got to distinguish
and set yourself apart so it's the need
for what you do then your ability to do
it
you've got to get really good at your
craft
you get it really good at being able to
communicate your value if Google is
going to have a you know a big Workshop
where they were going to bring in all
their cop Executives they're going to
hire somebody like Les Brown
and they're willing to pay him a hundred
thousand dollars I'm working now with Dr
Robert cialdini
um he's 125 000 a keynote and why
because he's Irreplaceable on that stage
when a company needs to communicate the
principles of influence and persuasion
there is no other person why because he
has established himself as as the very
best in the world he is not average
right and so I think that's something
that we want to be thinking about is how
can you set yourself apart and and
really be above average be exceptional
at something I love it let's do some
coaching let's do some q a let's bring
Zan on stage Zayn what do you got for us
Paul in the very beginning
um you you mentioned about content
coaching I think I know what you mean by
that but I'd like to see if you can
elaborate on that a little bit and how
did you create these connections how do
you shift from maybe mid-level coaching
to high-end premium
um packages yeah super so let's let's
unback that we're developing a
certification program right now for Dr
Robert cialdini and so you know he
teaches these seven principles of of
influence and so we're doing is we're
creating packages of coaching notes
coaching questions that a coach would be
able to
teach the principal so let's say they're
teaching the law reciprocity and so the
law reciprocity has three activators
it's not just about me giving something
there's three things that activate it so
number one is it has to be unexpected
number two it has to be meaningful
number three it has to be customizable
so me giving you you know a sweatshirt
with my name on it
is it meaningful to you it's not
customized to you right but if I have
something that has your name on it or if
they give you a nice and Yeti mug that's
customized to you and so what I would
then do is I would say okay now now you
know this principle now you understand
it so I've I've given you knowledge I've
now taught you something which coaching
is not about right and now let me ask
you when you think of this principle of
reciprocity and you think about giving
something you know that's unexpected
giving something that is Meaningful
giving something that is customizable
think of who you've got in your book of
prospects and what could you give right
now or what could you create so now I'm
going to coach you into creating a
strategy for how you could apply
reciprocity so that's what I mean by by
content coaching you know we're on the
same page yeah I was thinking the exact
same thing once you create the cocktail
that how do you
help them Implement what you're teaching
them and increase that transformation
Evan and I were talking earlier is is
that you know when people can live and
they they want they want you to be
everything they want you to solve tell
me what to do and then would you do it
for me right yeah and you said they've
got to have a team that can execute or
they have to find a team that could do
that right and so I think when you're
working with the client they they want
you to give them the solution they want
they want to attract to run on I just
think that you know more and more
um traditional coaching is dying by the
wayside as a matter of fact I'm friends
with the person right now who's writing
new coaching guidelines for uh for the
for the ICF and there's some spirited
debate going on let's say the second
question you ask is you know how did how
do you make that jump that to make these
connections yeah yeah it was something
Deb and I were talking about before the
show you either build an audience rent
an audience or buy an audience okay I
love it you can build an audience
uh build a YouTube channel build a
social media presence and I think
um is it fair to say that you know that
that build is a three three year build
or sure yeah to five year build so yeah
you know it's it it it works those you
know those subscribers those followers I
mean that's the gold standard is you
know someone who raises their hand and
says that you know I'm somewhat
interested in you and I'm going to be
engaged with with you and follow you
doesn't get much better than that but it
is a it's a it's not cheap to do
um oftentimes what happens for most
entrepreneurs is you know now they're
gonna now they're gonna learn how to
build a YouTube channel then they're
gonna learn how to write email content
then they're gonna you know and they go
down the rabbit Hall of learning all
these other things rather than becoming
a true pro at what they do right and and
either bartering or hiring out those
other services
so you could do the Slow Burn and I
think you've got to do that anyways I
think you've got to build a social media
presence you got to be able to have that
um you could rent an audience in you
know by doing getting yourself on
podcasts getting yourself out and and
doing free speaking engagements there's
lots of ways to do that and it's it's
very effective if you're willing to you
know
communicate concisely add value whenever
you're speaking
um make sure that you understand the
audience have an offer have something
for somebody to do a call to action if
you will I think if you're going to be
really effective at that game
again you have to be able to step in and
reciprocate and so if you're just going
in and being a taker you know I'm just
of the belief that givers gain right I
could build an audience I can rent an
audience or I could buy an audience and
so for me that's what I did I paid Bob
Proctor three hundred thousand dollars
we started a company called life success
Consultants Bob had a big following and
so
let me just share with you I think
um this is a really great lesson for
everybody to learn and I wish I'd have
learned it a lot
a lot sooner than when I did learn it
right uh I'm one of those guys that uh
you know I'm never led by the feather
I'm you know I'm led by the two by four
you know what I mean
and uh uh you know I've got phds from
the school the Hard Knocks I think
what we do is we partner up we
collaborate across and we Mentor around
okay and so one of the mistakes I see so
many coaches doing is they'll find
somebody who has similarities to them
and let's face it entrepreneurship is a
is a lonely game right I mean it's you
can get you know you're doing it all
yourself and you know that's what's so
wonderful about this community that
you've created is you've got you've got
Partners in belief you've got people who
encourage you you've got a place that's
trust it a lot of a lot of entrepreneurs
don't have that and so what they'll do
is they'll meet somebody you know at a
networking meeting and they say you know
why don't we partner up and the next
thing you know they get themselves into
some kind of a an established agreement
that takes them you know five years and
you know fifty thousand dollars to get
out of right so I think you only partner
up with those people who can bring value
that you don't have
then you can't develop and that you
can't buy you know when I partnered as
an example with John Maxwell it would
have taken me years to build an audience
like John has built now could I sure
could I get that good could I get that
impactful short but it might you know
he's he's 30 years older than me and so
I mean he's already got that Network so
what I found was by partnering up I was
able to put myself in a position of
influence and Authority
and just through the social proof of
having you know John or Bob Proctor or
Bob berg or Dr Daniel Amen or Joseph
McLendon or now Dr Robert shelbini be my
partner it kind of you know it gave me
that gold seal that otherwise I would
have to go out into the marketplace and
prove myself now you know I'd have to
bring back I had to bring value to those
guys right uh because nobody wants a
freeloader so those are those are the
three ways you can you can build it you
can rent it you can buy it and then I
think I'm a big believer when Emerson
said Emerson said do the thing
and then you get the energy to do the
thing and so you know you have to how do
you get to that next level first off I
believe you know life and death begins
in the tongue you've got to claim it
you've got to you've got to just start
claiming that this is what you are this
is who you this is what you do and
you've got to stop shooting low if
you're Aiming High
and it's I remember Les Brown said you
know most people fail at life not
because they aim too high and message
because they end too low and hit
and so if if you're going after those
higher clients then you know there's the
the vacuum law Prosperity you need to
make good you need to make room for the
good that you want in your life and so
if you continue to fill your book with
clients that aren't high level there's
no way you could take on the the the
that higher paying or higher standard
client so you've got to make sure that
there's space for them and then you need
to aim and shoot for them
and recognize your Drucker said fail
fast fell first fail often be willing to
know that there's going to be a certain
amount of burn until you get your value
proposition right your ability to
communicate your value and the offer
right and and what trips most people up
is they don't know how to price
themselves
and they think pricing is an issue of
pricing and pricing is never an issue of
pricing it's an issue of value when
somebody comes to me and says you know
how much should I charge for my service
they're immediately announcing their
ignorance to me of their value let's get
Nancy in here with her question my
question is I have
been with an opportunity to go into a
company give essentially one of those
free presentations
and what happens is I get to the sales
pitch and I shut down but what's really
cool about this opportunity is it's
something that I now realize I can go in
and pitch in a bunch of other companies
as well as do a live webinar in Ontario
so the basis is I have an engineering
background for 25 years the Professional
Engineers in Ontario have just required
rolled out a new mandatory requirement
for all Engineers to get
um to do continuing education
one of the requirements is around
communication which is where I
specialize so I'm going to go in and
take advantage of this new ruling and
start to pitch this in company but what
happens is I get to the point of doing
the sales and then I like shut right
down fifth any suggestions would be
grateful
yeah I think I think you know one of the
neuro linguistic programming principles
is this principle of reframing right
and you're probably Nancy you're
probably familiar with this idea of you
know selling isn't something you do to
someone it's something you do for
someone and I think it first before you
go in first reframe that and recognize
that information and content changes
nothing
nobody's like Changed by your talk right
right what would happen is is that could
spawn somebody to take the next step in
transformation and the next step so what
your talk will do is establish awareness
which is critical all transformation
begins with awareness right what you
want to do is you want to position this
as their next logical step and so when
you sell like you said you know when I
get to the pitch you get to the pitch as
soon as you say good morning and thank
you the pitch has started if you're
waiting to sometime at the end to pitch
it will feel like you're pitchy so
here's a great line that I say thank you
very much for for having me
um I'm going to share with you seven
principles that have really changed my
adverbs effective tools of communication
now I likely won't have at my command
the time to cover all seven so I'm going
to cover right I'm going to cover the
top three and I promise
that when I get to the end I'm going to
share a way that we can work more
formally together
fair enough okay and everybody will say
yeah
and then what I'm going to do is as I
talk about these three principles
I will refer to the four that I'm not
talking about and I'll talk about let me
you know let me give you an example when
I was work with you know in in my in my
six life communication program I had I
had Mary and Mary came with this problem
and so I'm I'm I'm I'm telling a story
I'm making a point it's all in the
framework of this of this future ask you
know what most people do is they wait to
the end they've got five minutes left
and now they say let me tell you about
my program right and they ambushed the
sale
you don't want to Ambush yourself you
want to talk about your program all a
very natural way that this is this is
most people who come through this
program have found that their next step
is to get into my six-month program and
the reason for that is because this and
this and this this is the transformation
in a clear case with this Challenge and
this Challenge and this challenge
remember people will do more to avoid
pain than gain pleasure so you come you
you talk about the problems of you know
what developing the ability to
communicate is really costing them on
one level they think it's costing them
this and your job is to show them that
oh no it's costing you much more than
that and then as you get towards the end
you're going to say remember earlier
when I said that I would share how we
could work in a more formal way and
everybody will say yes and say well let
me let me share with you this program
that I've been talking to you about so
it's not like you know this is the first
time here and I've been talking about
this program this six-month
communication program all along this is
the next logical thing to come up in the
presentation I think it's a more elegant
way than you know creating a pitch Nancy
and then I think if you'll reframe it
that you can't help somebody unless they
buy something
yes I'm I'm excited
um can I ask a little twist on it so I'd
be asked to put this as a presentation
at one of the big oil companies here in
town
um and but then I was thinking about
reaching out to doing this for
um as like a webinar to reach broadly
across Ontario and so I'm curious does
it make sense to do that for free or
I've been getting feedback from people
I've received this a few times is that
if it's not paid they don't see value in
it and so like even if I charge
something like 49 buy what's your
thought on free versus like a small pay
I'm not necessarily sold that if people
get something complimentary that they
don't value I think people can see value
in something that's free
um right as long as it's truly valuable
in position right yeah
um I think I would I would certainly
test it and one great way to test it
would be to do you know a buy one get
one so when you register for 99 it
you're eligible to bring one other
person on your team with you you know
don't grow up you know don't grow alone
I think I would test it I think also
um Nancy there's there's a dynamic that
happens in front of a live audience
that doesn't happen in a webinar I've
seen very few
live talks
translate into webinars effectively
there's probably going to be some
nuances that will change so what I my
relation to you Nancy is I would first
deliver this top 10 20 times I would do
some of these complimentary speaking
engagements and oh my goodness I mean
I'm talking you know you got to do the I
call it the rubber chicken rounds right
so rotary kiwanas BNI groups right where
there's the rubber chicken for lunch
right we're giving the talk right so put
yourself out there and what you're doing
is you're testing the content you're
you're mastering your pacing you're
mastering your tonality uh not a big fan
of recording every single thing you do
so either it's audio or you just set up
your phone and just just record yourself
you know every single Monday morning in
football season every NFL player sits
down and watches the game they played
the night before right watching the
tapes and really sharpening your skills
and saying okay can I get better here
can I get better here and then think
about how would this translate I would
see if you can't get a small focus group
maybe some of the folks even at this on
this year to see if they would be
willing to you know get on the get on
the on the webinar and give you feedback
awesome you're gonna do great answers
you're welcome all right we got yeah
you're next to the house he is uh he's
outside he's on a hike or something
which is beautiful wherever he is what
do you got for us man I just thought dad
asked like many times like people come
to me for coaching I don't work I work
at all like as a real estate consultant
and I like I know I've been telling me
that coach team should be like by Next
Step so
I'm always wondering what to do I know
I've been mentioned her a few times what
to do but I'm also try to think maybe if
there's like uh a school or something
that you recommend like basically what
what what should be like my next step in
order to make that my main career let me
just ask you a question because you said
you know you don't know if this is your
next step right I want it to be my next
step I like I do it like anyways but I
just it's not nothing that I get paid
for so sometimes just people come to
you know just for me to listen uh what
do you know is your next step to do I
like to assassinate limiting beliefs as
soon as they present themselves and so
when you fortify this I'm not sure you
you are you're 100 sure you know exactly
what your next step is what's your next
step being a life coach like helping
people you know go through their
challenges forward hearing them
accountable yeah so I forbid you you're
forbidden from ever saying again that
you don't know because you do know you
know exactly what your next step and
you're gonna be great at it because you
because you know this has called you
forward
this is a calling on your heart you know
it is and you're gonna be awesome at it
when you do it
um
Shane was plugged if that's okay so
coming up with with Dr Robert cialdini
he has a certification program where
again it's content-based so you would be
teaching principles of influence but in
there is a curriculum that teaches you
how to coach by probably one of the
world's top coaches the guy coaches from
the UN he's coached for futsy 100
companies
the alternative is going through you
know a school like an ICF or ipecker one
of the other ones that are teaching more
just traditional coaching but I think I
think you're going to find that it's
going to put you in a box
um because I think your heart is to
really you know want to guide people and
walk with them in their journey and so
if you'd like you know you could you can
look at this program there's many other
uh content providers that have
certification programs where the where
the coaching curriculum on how on the
skill to do it is really pretty good but
I also think
you're already doing this you're just
not getting paid and you haven't
formalized it people are already coming
to you you're a trusted and valued
source of of information for people and
so I think you know claiming that right
you can't export that which you don't
have so claiming that you know what I'm
already doing this I just haven't
formalized it might you need to get
better sure we all need to do the
biggest room in my house is the room for
improvement no doubt so I mean we all we
I mean we've all got to get better right
I don't think you need to wait to begin
I think I would go ahead and start
claiming it I'd start I'd I would start
charging people that when people say hey
can you help me you say absolutely what
here's here's the way I do this our
first session is complementary and then
I have packages from 90 days to to a
year
and so just establish that right from
the beginning yeah I appreciate that
thank you very much if I'll just add on
that just the sort of thing uh of course
that well so I'll go back down having a
message like I have to get to more
people but there's something like this
inside voice that because I really want
like to give the best to people I have
this voice thing that I always need to
learn more and improve more and and only
to then you know I could really turn
into something professional because I
want to give them the best but
you know it's I don't got the answer
it's always learning but I'm trying to
get rid of that voice to start yeah so I
mean I I think you know we're we're
going to be really blessed today we're
going to have um you know uh Earl Earl
nightingale's uh wife yeah Diana Diana
here today Earl Nightingale probably
gave the best definition of success I
ever heard he said that success is the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal so an ideal is an idea you've
fallen in love with and he said to be
successful all you have to be is in the
Progressive realization of that it's not
about reaching some Final Destination
it's that you're in The Game of Life
and
I truly believe that the universe will
never send you someone that you can't
help the fact that they are in front of
you is evidence that you can help them
and so you were already prepared
everybody who's going to come to you
you're prepared I believe that you're
fully resourced for any opportunity or
challenge that comes to you yeah
might you have to develop some skills to
access those resources for sure no doubt
we all do however those resources are
within you and the best way to access
them is to put you in a position where
where you're forced to stretch and grow
you're going to do great you really are
thank you we got Shaq Wukong in the
house what do you got man I've heard you
say before that you have always played a
very good number two was I really that
resonated with me because I am the
second child and I've always been a good
player too you like as like a good
person who always backs up somebody else
but I've gotten tired of that spot but
at the same time maybe I should embrace
it more because it's helped me to be a
better Coach it's helped me to be a
better uh professional at what I do I'm
a Ricky and acupressure to live this
which I end up becoming something like a
um
a behavior coach and a uh us like a sort
of coach of the metaphysical also
another thing that I relate with you on
too is that throughout my life I've
struggled with this speech impediment as
well one thing I wanted to ask you man
because with uh with my clients uh I
have a few who struggle with uh
confidence and the thing that you said
that I loved was that there's a
difference between your health image and
self-esteem and that for you that kind
of was like a root article battle with
your speech impediment of stuttering
um so if you can coach me on what
someone could do to sort of come out of
their and overcome their their limiting
beliefs I think there's great power in
in being a king maker uh that's you know
the role of number two is being the king
maker
um it affords you great opportunities uh
a great position of leadership
assuming you got a really good number
one right if you don't have a really
good one then be number two stinks right
not a great position so you want to make
sure that you got a really good number
one that you can respect that you value
um and I think you know one the power of
things that I've developed in
recognizing that I was a very good
number two is is that you know when I
embrace
be number two I'm reminded to always put
the other guy first
and that's you know that's the guiding
principle of life right
um and so
I embrace being number two and and I
don't do it from a place of
marginalization I I recognize that you
know I could absolutely be number one I
can absolutely take the stage I can hold
my own I clearly know that and yet I
also know that there's a part of me that
loves to serve people there's a part of
me that loves to be part of a team uh I
I thrive in that I grew up without a
father and so so looking for that
validation or looking for that
you know that that person to be proud in
you feeds that me being number two I
think the way we have to develop
confidence is Emerson said do the thing
and then you get the energy to do the
thing speakers speak and so
um there's a couple of things I think
first off is
um you just on on your computer I think
you you start by turning the computer on
turning the camera on and delivering
your first talk whatever it is don't
worry about it being perfect and then go
back get it transcribed and watch that
tape and watch that watch that video
again with the transcription and say
okay words mean things words have value
let me make sure I'm picking the
expensive words let's make sure I'm
picking the most you know like the high
value words let's make sure I know that
you know a picture's worth a thousand
words so how can I make this more
concise
and and I think over time
reparation
dispels doubt right like when fear
enters logic leaves and so the more you
can work with your talk yourself
speaking and communicating this way I
mean I when I first started you know my
my dogs would see me come in the living
room they get up and run because they
knew they were about to get a seminar
right if you came to my house you know
you were getting a seminar and so I I
would I would I would you know I would
practice little vignettes I was I was
always practicing being able to
communicate you know it's kind of like
if you golf if you took a one golf
lesson from a golf pro boy they can move
the needle in a big way it's a lot
easier to take a speaker who's at a
level eight and get them to attend than
somebody who might be at a three and get
them to a seven or an eight you could do
that in in relatively short time so I
think
um finding something that you're
passionate about to talk about is is
really critical and it sounds like you
are it sounds like you found you know
what it is that you're passionate about
and you know I I was fortunate enough to
to go through a bill goes speaker
training he trained everybody he trained
Zig Ziglar he trained ogmandino
and you know the guiding principle is
you know make a point and tell a story
you never tell a story without a point
you never make a point without a story
and you've got you've got stories you've
got you've got experiences in life and
so if you could think of those we'll
call them vignettes if you can think of
those stories and you know what's what's
the what's the guiding principle that
I'm trying to share here and really what
you're doing is you're you're sharing
what through what I call Hot
communication honest open and
transparent
you know there's a saying that says you
know people can spot a phony a mile away
and that's just so true
you know so be be authentic I remember
when I when I first started to speak
um I was with again with Les Brown and I
was trying so hard not to stutter and he
said now stutter people love an underdog
people love to see you struggle they'd
love to see you up there
imperfect right it's kind of like when
you see Joel Olsteen the bastard don't
you wish one time you would have some
spinach in his teeth I mean he's just so
perfect right his speech is just so
perfect you want to add just bill go
said you what you want to do is you want
to get your speech perfect and then add
warts you'll just you want to you want
you want to be human and relatable yeah
I hope that helps you we got uh Carla in
the house hey Carla hi Paul hi Evan
thank you so much Evan always for
bringing the best guests ever and Paul I
did look you up too and I don't know how
I haven't heard of you I am a student of
Bob Proctor and I feel his spirit in the
house
um so I work to create conscious content
that really eliminates those limiting
beliefs the paradigms and all of that
just like you have and that's why I'm
attracted to you know believe and arts
to limiting beliefs in the paradigms and
all of that stuff and I loved the
Winner's image she's got that um you
know all of his programs um and the way
we were speaking was you know about the
path to agreement you know Bob's thing
and I always have my little guy here
it's like we we communicated on levels
of all of it and so when it comes to and
I'm a consultant for Bob you know as he
I was with him until he passed and I was
one of his you know students but what
attracted me I think all coaches are
great and and where we resonate with the
level we're ready for
and so for me
I I struggle with but I'm I'm not
anymore like it's not sexy to be
disciplined and to study Bob is all
about repetition he was a student every
morning five o'clock thinking girl rich
I have my psycho cybernetics here right
like Thomas trollward that's some deep
that's not
it's that way not from where
so
that's my goal and what I resonated with
you with is when it comes to coaching
it's not popular to focus on the inner
world the spiritual world and that's
what I loved about and I think it still
original to Bob in the sense of even
Earl Nightingale and
um
you know uh just these people anyways so
my question to you is how do would you
see it
or what would you tell someone like me
who really wants to take these
principles
and
really share it with an audience and I'm
not saying it's in a deeper way like
more special than the surface you know
go go kind of stuff but
how do you steal which would your advice
be to me kind of on my journey in
sharing this information that's
wonderful well thank you so much I was I
was telling Evan before the show that
you know I started I was blessed I I was
out cold calling in my cleaning business
going door to door-to-door in 1990 and I
walked in this guy's office who was
worth a couple of hundred million
dollars he pulled off the book thinking
we're rich and for three years he
mentored me and
um introduced me to Bob Proctor and at
that time the number one kind of
infomercial was Tony Robbins with Fran
Tarkington the the football player and I
never walked on hot calls I was studying
dead Masters trailers and Karma off
right and I'm so grateful because all of
those other you know everything past
said all comes it all roads go back to
True Word right exactly I love you like
the short word his essay on completeness
is just one of the spirit of opulence
and Bob and I I don't know if you ever
saw Bob and I did a program called the
art of thinking uh so yeah art of
thinking it was about three hours long
and I just interviewed Bob and it was
amazing he was incredible but I I think
you know there's lots you're right
there's lots of great coaches and
speakers
and that leave the spiritual component
out and they're good they're just
incomplete I don't know how you talk
about creating something and leaving the
Creator you know God God the grand
overall designer out of the equation
right I think you've got to be able to
introduce that spiritual component and
so I think Never back down from that but
recognize you're introducing the
spiritual component not the religious
component absolutely
and and I think I think we knew when you
stay on the side of spirituality and and
you know the vignette you know we're you
know we simultaneously live on three
planes of existence we're Spiritual
Beings gift within intellect living in
and through a physical body
and and everything that manifests in the
physical world is expressed through its
polar opposite of spirit everything is I
think people underestimate the
audience's ability to go deep and I
think that there's a thirst I think
there's a thirst and a hunger for it I
think people want I mean that that's
that's what this show is all about is is
you know you guys are having big talk
here you know that small thought this is
Big Talk yeah and and I think people are
hungry for it so I would say you know
again going back to hot hot
communication honest open and
transparent
and I think I think what's important is
is that never underestimate your journey
you know
I I believe in God and so you know God
God puts a person in front of you
um share your journey
yeah air your journey share the impact
share you know where you were where you
are and and that you know I always say
if I were a piece of marble Michelangelo
would still be you know chipping away
I'm not done yet I'm I'm still I'm still
in process and and share your words
share your failures right and I think
you could go do that
um and I think I think the audience will
go deep with you
all right let's bring up Brian and see
what he's got for us hey Brian how do we
begin to get to those higher paying
higher ticket clients so that we can
sell our was it three thousand dollars
or was it two thousand dollars for our
coaching program we're playing two
thousand dollar coaching program for
three months because our audience
is Geeks Gamers and pop culture nurse
basically the guys who go to the Comic
Cons or the guys who buy the video games
and video game systems and sit around
gaming and also have lives to their own
you know families and things but they're
single
and a lot of them that we're seeing in
our audience that we're attracting
they
can't really afford
like even over the payment plan they
can't really afford a 700 a month
coaching program one-on-one with us but
they could afford a course they could
even afford a book once we get the book
out so how do we eventually reach those
higher ticket people like how do we
reach those higher paying clients we can
start generating the income that we
really need and generating the booth
what we really need yeah okay thanks
Brian congratulations for being on your
journey this is awesome and finding your
voice in it I'm going to say some things
that might make you a little bit
uncomfortable
um but I think I think it's important
right and so
one of the things that I I I learned in
the there's a little book called as a
man thinking that's 62 Pages you can
read in an hour and study it for a
lifetime he says in life we don't get
what we want we get Who We Are
right and so I would ask you to think
are you spending three thousand dollars
for a program when was the last time you
spent three thousand dollars for a
program or a coaching program have you
done it
three years ago
so it's hard to take people where you
haven't gone or don't frequent right so
make sure make sure that you're
investing in yourself right make sure
that you're you're congruent with what
you're asking other people to do that's
number one number two is never say no
for other people you're saying no for
people you're saying well they can't
they they can't afford it and granted
some of them can't
and but my question is is is in there
can't is it a lack of potential or lack
of willingness
I think it's probably willingness
because those same people who are gaming
have consoles and all kinds of tolls and
things that they gained with that they
spent much more than three thousand
dollars on right people will spend
to get their problems solved
or their needs met
if it's positioned them that way so I
think you need to really think of what's
the value proposition what's the
transformation that's going to happen if
somebody gets into your coaching program
right and so I I don't want you to make
an agreement with the limitation that
people can't afford it
um some may not be able to but in most
cases it's a question of their
willingness to do it
the the other thing I I would I would I
would say Brian is I think you're really
smart to have a book and then a program
and you're creating this buyer's Journey
and I think what happens is when
somebody buys your book and they get
value and maybe they're ready to take a
99 course and then they're ready to take
a 299 course and then 997 and you're
guiding them up
one of the things that you might want to
consider doing
is once you have this buyer's Journey
you know completed when somebody comes
in at let's say the 99 level and some
people will some people will on-ramp
right at 99 so people are long ramp at a
thousand and others might start at a
book for 14.99 right but wherever they
are what I would do is I would honor
a um a growth commitment
and what I would say to then Brian is is
I'm so committed to your growth that if
in the first 90 days you get into this
99 program if you want to upgrade to the
997 you keep the 99 program and I'm
going to apply 100 of the 99 to the 997.
in other words I'm gonna make the first
investment in you right and so you're
you're creating an easier path for them
to say yes
it's probably congruent with your values
to want to help people anyways
and
so I think continue to build
and whenever you're speaking to your
audience Brian I think you want to say
for some of you you know your next step
is the 997 program you know that's your
next step and there's probably something
that's holding you back from do it doing
it and what I want to encourage you to
do is I want you to I want you to really
stretch
and bet on yourself I want you to see
yourself as worthy as betting it and
turn it into what it really is which is
a self-esteem issue people don't you
know it's really hard for somebody who
doesn't value themselves to invest three
thousand dollars in themselves
right so you might have to do some some
building of their belief in that process
that's a really important piece of this
process and I think
um one last kind of you know pricing
Dynamic strategy uh one is obviously you
want to be able to
honor a past commitment to a future
commitment you also want to look at at
your guarantees
and I would offer a 100 money back I
offer 100 money back guarantee on
everything I offer
um I want to make it safe for somebody
to bet on themselves
uh I I think if you were to just Google
search statistics I think less than one
percent of the people ever asked for a
refund anyways and you position the
refund this way that if you if you
complete the entire course of curriculum
and apply it for 90 days if at the end
of 90 days you don't believe that it was
worth the investment or you didn't get a
return on the investment you let us know
return your money a hundred percent
that's what I would do Brad you've been
doing such a great job with coaching and
just diving in and we still got lots of
hands up people want to ask for
questions so maybe we do a round two or
some Publishers but any final thoughts
up there kind of getting a Vibe now for
the the group as well as if people want
to dive into more of your story your
journey your newsletter whatever the
next step is for them we'll think what
do you got so you can reach out to me at
uh at Omar
nelly.net Walmart nelly.net and then
also um you can go to geldini.com
sheldini.com uh and connect with me
there but here's here's what I would
leave you with if there is one thing
that really changed my life
it was the it was the truth of the
awareness that
any idea you get
you are fully resourced to bring that
forward you would literally would be a
universal impossibility for you to be
able to have the idea to be do or have
what it is you want to be do or have and
not be fully resourced to bring it out I
love it no thank you amen thank you
that's all right thank you so much for
that honor what an honor to be with all
of you today all of you thank you so
much if you want to join us in movement
makers check the link in the description
below otherwise enjoy this video right
here I think you'll love it